greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by on it for all your supplement
needs and it will be there for you from
shrimp export to shroom tech immune to
alpha brain the [ __ ] backbone of the
organization let me tell how strong
alpha brain is if you don't like it
they'll give you your money back and
they'll even want the product back
that's how much they believe in alpha
brain number two and it's got a new
program called on it six it's a home
workout that you could do right in your
[ __ ] house it'll change your body in
six weeks call on at six well not at
that time right now press in church band
and get 10% off sent right to your
[ __ ] house after you people
always torture me Joey what kind of give
you that I'm a fat [ __ ] I need a big key
its Fuji [ __ ] that's the key you
need whether it's Aggies whether it's
the mouthpiece whether it's a shin guard
whether it's the mats Fugees been around
since Jesus left Chicago you understand
me the first samurai had a Fuji [ __ ]
key on BC before [ __ ] Chino showed up
nevermind Christ Chino showed up before
[ __ ] Christ all right but anyway go to
Fuji Sports calm right now press in
church ban and get 10% off like a
[ __ ] you understand me and
that's it and that's that kick this
[ __ ] melee what's the story Tom
Rhodes what's up Joey Diaz I'm happy to
have you back on here [ __ ] the
Christ's killing full effect it's a
beautiful day to be alive that's a
Christ killer the original before
[ __ ] Jesus even know about him he's
looking for Jesus left Chicago like it
was first Chino or could the Christ
killer Chino okay Chino came first
Chinese guy came first before Jesus
first got his smoke pot was Chinese you
know that some guy Confucius said the
journey of a thousand miles begins with
the first step and I always think only a
Chinese guy would walk that far [ __ ]
yeah
Confucius has some good [ __ ]
saying I'm saying that's why he was
Confucius he would confuse you I just
want spareribs
I just want spareribs I've been obsessed
with since I went to Mongolia I've been
obsessed with jenga's Khan
I read his biography and really that
[ __ ] nasty I haven't bad [ __ ]
yeah and so they all they ate was meat
and you know and drank milk so the
Mongolians had like really strong bones
and they went down and rolled through
China and those different dynasties and
kingdoms they were vegetarian so they
could slice through their bones really
easily because they were so like kind of
thin and brittle sorry you shouldn't you
mentioned China and I just think about
the Mongolians rolling through and they
like to attack in winter they love to
winter because the rivers and the moats
were frozen and they could just roll
right over it and then in summer their
arrows weren't as accurate because they
were a little you know the heat would
you know soften him up a little bit
speaking of had seen this and I wanted
to look it up to make sure I was right
in in the area where he was ruling than
in Asia eight percent of the men living
in that area are related to them so if
you do to like 23andme or whatever that
is ancestry.com in Asia you have like if
you're a man they have 16 million
descendants of Genghis Khan living today
that's how many people you know they did
so much [ __ ] everywhere and he did
apparently and so I did a show in in
Mongolia I'm gonna go back in almost all
Mongolia yeah Mongolia is amazing and
I'm gonna go back in August and that was
my opening I said apparently everyone in
the world is somehow related the jenga
scones so I'm just here to visit family
hello cousins I'm Chinese yeah that's
Ganga sent me I'm saying I would believe
that but my grandma fought Ganga
somewhere along the line but I didn't
know I I read something about him when I
was locked up I read like a paragraph
about Genghis Khan it was like guys the
meanest guys and civilization was he was
a pretty badass ruler because he wasn't
and another thing like under the rule of
jenga's Khan no individual was held ever
held responsible for a mistake or an
error it was the community's fault as a
whole so I said that in my show and I
so if this show doesn't go well tonight
it's all of our fault how does it go
because it cools great man and people
are so sexy they're like there they are
high cheekbones and really just just
stunningly beautiful people I they look
like avatar without the blue you know
they're just really beautiful people and
and then and there you know super
friendly not a lot of people travel
there and food is amazing it's meat on
top of meat with a side dish of meat and
I loved it and if you learn anything
about the country before you go there
they go crazy they love it now when you
go to these places
what's your passport look like I'm on my
fourth passport I just got a new one
about six months ago which is too bad
because my last passport I had extra
pages put in it twice so it was really
thick and I did it and it I filled it up
it was so great you that's the you can't
get more than two extra twice you can
get extra pages put in it that was the
limit that's as thick as an American
passport can get and you know it's
beautiful I got stamps from everywhere
how hard is it for you to get into those
kind unless you have to plan your tour
I'm like get visas from all these places
or do you just book plane tickets well
like China for example I've been to
China so many times about five years ago
I don't know if they're still doing this
if you were a frequent frequent visitor
to China they they were given out the
10-year visa so I got the 10-year visa
for China again which is great because
in LA you would have to go to the
Chinese consulate which is like oh my
god where it's between Wilshire and 6th
somewhere down there in Koreatown and it
was a day you'd have to you know did you
get in line and drop off your passport
photos and the the forms would take a
day and then picking them up place was
always really crowded and everything so
to have the tenure visas really a luxury
know when you do
family in Mongolia who clums mongolia
was all Mongolians there were two
Americans there was an Australian guy an
American woman and they were the only
two non Mongolians there and the rest of
the audience was so cool on Betar is the
capital city of Mongolia and they call
it ub city for short and the comedy club
there is called ub city comedy club and
i think it seats maybe 150 and i think i
had like probably 95 96 people great
turnout and i I was interviewed on the
bloomberg television of Mongolia they
were under Soviet you'll rule forever
and so they just got rid of the Soviet
Union the Russians like I don't know 20
30 years ago so like they're really just
embracing capitalism after not having
[ __ ] under being communist forever now
what's the guy's name it was a comedy
club like what Todd well I demand the
name Zaire
I I don't know the I didn't meet the guy
that owns the comedy club but the names
there there's a comedian they're called
Zolo and that's just what English people
call him his name is actually like you
know I'm friends with him on Facebook
he's the best friend I made there I love
this guy is but his real his real name
is like 12 letters long and then you
meet people there with names like I
arrived at the airport and and five
Mongolian comedians picked me up at the
airport and it was great they cheered
when I came out and they just bent over
backwards showing me their country while
I was there you know they're comedians
were brothers and the dude driving it
tells me his name is Steve and I got
come on man I can handle your Mongolian
name what's your real name and the guy
goes what the guy's name was a noise and
I talked about it on stage I go the
guy's name was and they go oh yeah
that's like a really common name in
Mongolia
am I not bullshitting yeah I go okay
you know what your name is the guys I go
okay Steve
hahaha like they got their people there
that their their languages really sounds
really melodic and beautiful but some of
the names are like noises you make after
you've had a large meal so from Mongolia
where you go do comedy what's the next
comedy club after the [ __ ] Mongolia
what do you hear country means to it
roads between China and Russia so that
we've done commonly in Russia yeah I
know but I've been to st. Petersburg
I've filmed when I lived in Holland I
did a year as a presenter on a travel
show so I got to I got to film a
highlight on st. Petersburg incredible
city lots of canals styled after
Amsterdam The Hermitage probably one of
the greatest museums in the world
Catherine the Great had people agents
all going all over Europe buying up
Rembrandt paintings Rembrandt had fallen
out of style and she so they got the
largest collection of Rembrandt's it's
pretty pimp now when you do China
you've gone China yeah cuz re when China
goes was all Americans that show that
Wow yeah that Apple was something he
said he was telling me I don't [ __ ]
know I you know half the audience will
be international people you know we won
the language we won the lottery when it
comes to the language the you know 300
years ago the international language of
business was French
now it's English because of the Internet
you know look at airline pilots they got
to be able to communicate in English no
matter what country they're from to land
and I don't know if that's totally true
but so that none is - really - but right
but did you hear that yeah yeah yeah I
think I saw it as like a fact I don't
know if any of those post a real but but
despite when you someone I'm playing in
China the audience is yeah half the
audience will be internationals from
everywhere you got Australians Canadians
Irish English you know Italians German
Swiss and and then half the audience
will be Chinese Chinese American Chinese
Canadian Chinese English whatever and
then Chinese people who were educated in
Western
countries and love English language
comedy so it's usually half chinese and
half international in China now where do
you go to next now I'm going to
Philadelphia I'm gonna be at the
punchline in Philadelphia July 28th to
the 30th and this is the first time I've
been back in Philadelphia since I got
this scar on my forehead cause when I go
since I got sober when I I was so drunk
in Philadelphia and I blacked out and
fell off that barstool like a tree and
[ __ ] busted my head open and
Philadelphia's a great city to get a
scar in you know that the the couple
days I was there walking around and I
had the fresh stitches on my forehead
and I had a black eye I got so much
street credibility from all the homeless
dudes in Philadelphia what happened to
you big man did you get into a rumble
you know the great how long ago was this
two years ago four years ago see but so
before you yeah how's it feel feels
great yeah did you ever think you would
be clean never know I never thought like
the weirdest thing ever ever in my life
thought I would not be drinking and not
be smoking cigarettes it was such a big
part of my life love I still love booze
and I still love cigarettes just trying
to get some [ __ ] done and squeeze a few
extra years of living you know how long
have you been cleaning from the
cigarettes three years once I quit the
booze I thought [ __ ] I'm if I could do
that I bet I could kick the cigs and the
cigs were harder definitely you know I'm
still sucking on the nicotine lozenges
once in a while let me ask you this was
the age a big factor in this like for me
I could tell you that I got clean yeah I
got clean but but I also think that I
was just tired
I was tired of being in that position
and have no long [ __ ] time you know
yeah I'm like [ __ ] 17 years that I
hadn't
I had a day off like I went up some
[ __ ] men in hardcore you and I and
when we met you know in Houston we were
voting that's why we hit it off so well
I come in like hey this is a guy who
[ __ ] goes as hard as I do yeah when I
committed the comedy it's a party
yeah why that I was mine I always
thought it'd be when a comedian yeah
part of it was being the life of the
party and being you know I don't know
life of the party I just knew I had a
party yeah I didn't want to be a life of
a planning the one nobody knowing I was
holding I just knew that part of the
mystique of getting into economy was the
drug part of it that we'll have no
responsibility to life yeah whatsoever I
did not have the same responsibilities
as other people had that was part of me
part of the award are they allure was
that that I lost control but I really
didn't that was part of the allure that
you lose control but you really did it
you know I'm thinking about why I
thought the Netflix special wasn't so
good Norma tell you why because I got
scared that's not me I'm the type of guy
I don't give a [ __ ] when I go on stage
this is what I'm saying this is how I'm
delivering it either you're on board or
you're off board for years that was my
backbone of County the last two years
I've been thinking that way you know
that pain to come see me I have to make
them go away happy feeling I'm saying
it's yeah what it used to be yeah when
you first started doing comedy
so that allure of being crazy is what
really grabbed me about comedy if I
wanted to go home and be in bed at 10
o'clock and then it couldn't become a
mechanic or a doctor or got a girlfriend
that wasn't once you become a comic you
commit to this a whole other that's
where you get your material from that's
where you get your passion from it's
going into the unknown not knowing a lot
of people can't go into the unknown not
knowing that's a certain gift when you
go on a trip will run you basically go
into the unknown not knowing you know
you don't know what's gonna happen
when it's only going to the points line
in Philadelphia it's not like go into
the punch line in San Francisco but life
is such is like that anyways without
drinking and do it like none none trust
my mom down on it no guys here but it
like your wife you assemble in line you
can Everton can do that and you got the
it's the magic ticket you're partying
every night especially like in the 80s
and the in the 90s it was like drugs
were everywhere and then it's you know
free drinks everywhere and calmly thing
was living on a tight rope with no meant
I thought I was part of the Rolling
Stones I dressed to catch up to the band
either yeah me too I didn't want there
to be a net that was part of me the
reason I got into comedy I was going
against Society and what society
believed it right I don't want to do
what society does I never want to do
with society there's never ever ever
ever do I want to be a part of society
in that way I always wanted to beat to
my own [ __ ] drum yeah I'll do things
that you guys do but that's not the
purpose while I'm living I never wanted
to live for the Joneses when I read
ladies and gentlemen Lenny Bruce and he
was living at the Chelsea it's doing
heroin which strippers that was the life
I wanted if you woke up with chlamydia
you take a shot and you go back on stage
on a Thursday night that's just the way
you know that was the allure I got into
it this part this life that I'm living
now with agents and managers and wives
and children this wasn't I have accepted
this this is the next level of comedy
every warrior needs to eventually
Miranda weisbarth or Weisman yeah but
it's so funny the allure of comedy for
me was saying [ __ ] you to society I had
already done time I was already
considered a Hells Angel whether I
wanted to or not Society I already put a
sticker on me I'm a felon if you're
gonna ride this wave out let's ride this
[ __ ] out why not be a funny
felon you were saying you know like an
angry felons they're all tatted up a
good time yeah well let's just be a
funny felon you know sayin maybe there's
an angle there and that was it that was
the angle I just wanted to be a funny
fountain I didn't
give a [ __ ] where I woke up you know
when you want a trouble when you leave
on Monday man you got on that Highway ya
know what's gonna happen
that's tremendous that feeling is
tremendous people dream of that people
go to bail it make jerkin off some
lanlan before me I'm gonna leave this
[ __ ] and I'm gonna get that card I'm
just gonna [ __ ] drive people say that
all the time they don't know that one
day it might come real home they like
I'm giving up my [ __ ] apartment oh
I'm don't calm I'm living my [ __ ] car
some people I did it everything exciting
it's romance exciting none other people
like are you crazy you can't live in you
call watch me and it's like I said on
this you know it's gotta be the same
when you travel and do comedy
internationally when you commit to the
universe the universe takes K the same
thing happens when you go to Mungo it
you know exactly get there and picks you
up anybody have weed for you anybody
know why the pine no no I would not know
in that and I don't know what Mongolia
is but like I know certain places just
in China and those different countries
in Asia all of the penalty for drugs is
execution so I don't [ __ ] with nothing
and it's great now I don't drink so it's
I don't um
I'm bright-eyed clear so cheers in Japan
- have you been thought of Japan is
death but most all the other ones in
part of Malaysia and the Philippines you
know in Japan on prisoners on death row
they do not know their day of execution
every when you're on death row in Japan
you wake up every day thinking this
might be my last alright I was in Japan
earlier this year I hadn't been to Japan
in ten years I read all this [ __ ] about
Japan and that was one little factoid
that I thought was pretty amazing and
then also have you commit suicide in
Japan by jumping in front of a train
your family is sent a bill for
disruption of service need that a
[ __ ] I mean those two facts are
kind of sad but to me like Japan's a bit
one country that like I really like
that's probably my number one
Japan's amazing it's like the Germany of
Asia it's like it's efficient it's clean
and they're fascinating people to like
the way they're so stylish
like I saw this dude in Tokyo and he had
full on yellow Adidas I put it on my
Instagram this dude was like he looked
like he was from Brooklyn and they like
gold chains like he was a rapper like
like a hardcore Brooklyn rapper from you
know 92 but it's Japanese guy living in
Tokyo I was in Osaka about ten years ago
and I saw these guys and they were you
know the car culture is big they're like
the like you know this kind of la hot
rod cars and stuff I told these these
dudes in Osaka they were dressed like
Mexican la gangbangers with even the
hair nets and the flannel shirts with
like the buttons too on the top and the
white shirt underneath these dudes are
just like like in the 80s when you'd see
like their role the 80s and 90s movies
would you see like movies of LA Mexican
gangbangers these guys studied that and
that's gonna be my style you know see
women over there wearing like fishnet
stockings in like a rain coat buttoned
up and like stiletto heels like what
perversions invented that style it's
just fascinating culture what they lock
onto it's funny when I lived in
Hollywood a Japanese woman lived in my
building it was pretty hot very hot very
sweet woman had a black boyfriend real
cool and she used to wear some outfits
then you would sit there and me and my
wife we just look alike our heads would
shake and she was a mom she did not give
a [ __ ] hot pants was fishnet stockings
and sneakers with no toes blue hair you
know she was just stylish as [ __ ]
and I used to snort coke and that
building and she would do power yoga for
the morning that's the only time she
could do pee yoga she would leave the
house and I called her for and walk from
Schrader and between sunset and [ __ ]
Hollywood Boulevard
she would walk this was way before the
conglomeration of Hollywood this is I'm
talking about mm you can get mug to the
Holly but it still gritty well he was
still gritty Messiah was her name I said
karma Messiah Messiah race to call him I
love him I still talk to him once a
month we stopped over there we say hello
to kids but she would [ __ ] leave the
building had called for I'd become tough
looking out the window and see Messiah
walking down the street
[ __ ] to yoga power yoga with hot
pants and heels and socks on
you know just the craziest outfit she
would change and she cuts head so she
would change her hair every [ __ ] week
I never saw nothing like that my life
very neat very cool and very real it was
an outfit she that's was who she writes
like most people have to get up and plan
and go to the tailor and you know shave
there no Messiah did everything there's
some people fake the funk she did it
perfectly she wasn't thinking about I
think the style setters for the world
are young American young black males in
America and young japanese girls and
women i think they are the you go to
japan whatever like young women are
doing you're gonna see that five ten
years later all over the world the way
like black american males you know the
same deal now when did you fall in love
with traveling cuz i will tell you one
thing i don't know dick about dick but
you are i don't know all the comics I
know the world travel I mean you really
have used it to your advantage this
comedy thing to travel and see the world
yeah so again some people fake the funk
when they travel they just want to seem
interesting so I'll tell you about these
places that are cool I've been to Ibiza
you know that's great yeah you don't
[ __ ] jerk off you don't think you got
chlamydia from [ __ ] that [ __ ] what's
that [ __ ] with a scroll left you see how
a is like [ __ ] on fire with gonorrhea
in committee alright see the billboards
around LA yeah
glad I missed all that statue I'm glad
that wasn't around when I was I never
did online dating never did online
hookups all that stuff but to what where
I started traveling you know I always
had wanted to travel I had a great
career as a comedian you know what you
know comedy central in the early days
and then that sitcom I always loved that
story that you tell when you saw me
after the my sitcom was was done at The
Improv and you said I was sitting at the
bar by myself and I look like I didn't
have a friend in the world yeah I love
that story because like it's true I've
[ __ ] with my head really and I didn't
you know I I am once your show gets
canceled people don't call back no more
everybody now they treat you like you
got canned yeah
it's [ __ ] and then all these people I
thought when my friend stopped taking my
phone call you know and like it was
[ __ ] up just the way people treat you
in LA after your show doesn't make it it
was like I'm still Tom Rhodes I'm still
a great comedian and I thought [ __ ] this
town and I moved back to New York
because I had lived in New York when I
was 20 like a dog I moved there from
Florida to be a comedian full of dreams
wasn't good enough I could only afford
to live in Washington Heights
this is 1987 as crack was coming to the
neighborhood there'd be gunshots in my
neighborhood on Cabrini Boulevard where
I lived in the morning there'd be
smoldering burned-out cars like people
would steal cars and lower Manhattan and
drive them up there and I'm living there
terrified and you or the guy with the
like let's do it so you took your car
it's a fact if you want you can
disappear you don't yeah so that's where
I lived and then that's all I could
afford to live in 1987 was one year
leave the car dealership yeah the driver
so either you call the right way so I
lived there like a dog and I always
swore if I ever had any money I'd live
in New York with style so when that
sitcom finished and then you know
showbiz going ice cold on me in Los
Angeles I moved back to New York got a
rockstar apartment in the Wall Street
area and I looked at all that money I
had is my NBC artist grant
so I started I was like man I got I got
dough I can do whatever I want so I
started taking trips to London and I was
focusing on New York I was still doing
road stuff and in the States my favorite
place is you know San Francisco Atlanta
Minneapolis Chicago Seattle you know the
the mice still my main places I love to
play and then I started making trips to
London and I got him with the Comedy
Store in London and then I started
playing London started bringing me over
regularly and in London is a really
exciting great place to to play
especially then there was so many clubs
in the the clubs paid decent and then
it's like you know nobody in Europe
knows that I had some sitcom they don't
give a [ __ ] all they care about is oh my
god you're a great comedian let's have
you on our stage let's invite you to
this party let's come with me whatever
and then that led to gigs all over
Europe and then I you know I'm playing
in Amsterdam and Paris and Berlin and
and then I fell in love with a Dutch
girl but also you know ended up moving
to Amsterdam but getting in with London
was the key to the world for me so that
also led to gigs in Asia and then comedy
festivals in Australia and and that's
how it that's kinda what kind of started
you know I always wanted to travel my
mother's from Argentina I had never been
there at that time now I've been there
three times you know and it's it's I've
had a really beautiful life as a
comedian and that it that allowed me to
travel and then all these magical things
happen to me like and then up you know
being offered my own television show on
Dutch television and doing that
late-night talk show in Amsterdam for
two years and then that was like like I
said I never liked soccer before I moved
to Holland I was you know kind of a
girlie sport or whatever but like the
Dutch are fanatical about it the English
are fanatical about it so I just really
started to like it and get into it there
you know I interviewed a couple of the
Dutch soccer players on my late-night
talk show and and then finally going to
Argentina the the
you know the land of my mother my family
and everyone in Argentina that's all
they care about that's their main
passion in life so my I went to a soccer
match in Argentina that ended in a riot
my family in Buenos Aires their favorite
soccer team is called River Plate and my
cousin Fernando took me to see River
Plate played kill miss which is a
factory town 20 miles outside of Buenos
Aires really intimidating we go into
this town and it's dirt roads and there
is cops everywhere I mean the most
vicious looking cops you've ever seen in
your life and they're holding shotguns
and they're holding an axe handles with
just you know just the wooden part of a
of an axe without the top part on it and
they're just looking at you as you're
coming into their town like please give
me a reason to bust your skull open and
then some of them have given German
shepherds and it's like holy [ __ ] so
this is how like insane South Americans
are about soccer these people will you
know just lose their mind and go berserk
and the the home fans sit separate from
the visiting fans and there's a wall
that separates them you can't even bring
lighters into the stadium the people
check-in you and there's like a big pile
of lighters so I don't know who started
the fire that eventually happens in this
story so kill mice's is is in this
there's a wall of razor wire around the
field not barbed wire razor wire a tall
big wall of razor wire so kill mice's
losing 4 to nothing and the home fans
were so upset at their own team for such
a poor performance they set fire to
their own Stadium and this is a South
American you know concrete stadium so I
don't know whatever they do breach
clothes paper you know coca-cola cups I
don't know what the [ __ ] or if somebody
brought in gasoline all the sudden the
other side of the stadium is engulfed in
flames and all the that we're on the
opposite side so there's this big gap
opens all the people over there now
getting away from the fire there's a
massive fire on the other side of the
stadium and
these lunatics like 40 or 50 people on
the other side of the stadium are trying
to get onto the field and they're
climbing the razor wire and then like a
hundred riot police came streaming
across the field in him the players
scattered because it's all the sudden
there's a fire and then all these
[ __ ] lunatics are trying to get on it
if they're climbing the razor wire and
these [ __ ] like up like a hundred
riot police in helmets and batons just
went streaming across the field and
they're just [ __ ] beating people off
the fence
and then they shot tear gas into the
stands it was [ __ ] it was it was
pretty intense man and then they let
then everybody had that they canceled
the match for there was like 20 minutes
left the games done the kill must is
forfeited it they've lost it they and
this was on a school night so they made
us wait in the stadium for two hours
before they would let it they didn't
want clashes in the streets so I don't
know why didn't I don't know why they
didn't keep the home fans locked in
there first
you know but they let the home side out
first and then fired to theirs I know
what's gonna fight but they live there
they could have waited I mean it's you
know it's a school night everybody's got
to work the next day so all these people
from Buenos Aires for the for the River
Plate they made us stay in the stadium
for like two hours and it's getting
these people are getting restless and
they're banging on the big steel walls
to be a doors to be let out and then
these [ __ ] kill must police start
shooting tear gas canisters into the
stadium to where we are waiting to be
let out
and these Argentinian people were very
used to tear gas canisters because they
just nonchalantly picked him up and
throw him back over the wall and [ __ ] I
was like oh [ __ ] it's like this is
intense you know but it was I would I
would I would rank it among probably
some of them one of the greatest
experiences of my life really it was so
cool yeah I mean at the time I was he
and especially when the tear gas started
coming over did like everybody there's
this animal instinct when you're in a
crowd
if you've ever been in a big crowd when
some [ __ ] happens
you can imagine likes gunshots go off
like how terrible the way people scatter
so there's a sort of animalistic
instincts we have when [ __ ] happens so
there was there was a couple moments
when you know the crowd surged and
people started you know pushing as a
whole they were a little terrifying but
it was pretty intense not how many we
see you do you travel uh
you know my wife does the finances so I
was on the road more days last year than
I was at home so what I've done in LA is
I'll be on the road two weeks a month
and I'll be on the road two weeks a
month but you know there's been like
last year I went to Asia for a month it
doesn't always work out like that but
those long trips she can't but she won't
we made a Hong Kong a couple months ago
and she'll go to the cities that she
loves New York and Chicago you know in
Austin Texas and no offense no offense
to be able to be listening at the house
you know on to this podcast but Anthony
Bourdain's dead don't feel so good
myself you know you really enjoy this
[ __ ] listen I know people fake the funk
in LA and they do anything to be cool
and you know they they they live by the
secondhand clothing and all that [ __ ]
you know you're real from the heart yes
this is a show you have here this is a
show that it's so weird how in today's
world you really don't need a lot of
things that you think you need you know
like right now I got like you could have
your wife come we got on those trips
tape you tape you interviewing somebody
you at the [ __ ] Club yeah you want a
restaurant that's a nine minute episode
you cut it and you put it up and you get
a travel pack or a [ __ ] something
that's that every traveler needs you get
them to sponsor you to go TV show and
even if you [ __ ] make a minimal
amount of money just enough to cover the
wife and you when the plane tickets that
[ __ ] and yeah it's really worth it to
show people your experiences I mean I
saw and then also comedians around the
world and what
what did what are people making somehow
somebody pen down the price I mean we've
talked about this because the time you
pitch this and sell it I don't beat my
20022 you're in no danger no but I've
already I've had this idea for years yes
I was was like this I was filming this
you have to five videos wherever I went
I made a pilot on Malaysia I did a lot
of different things yeah this is but
check it out the eye last year and my my
wife and I came up with a great format I
had the idea before but then she like
structured a formatted show and and we
chose ten cities around the world and
made the admit a structure of what that
those episodes would look like and the
people we would talk to and the things
we would do and example episodes
basically so pitch to the CN n pitches
the Comedy Central pitch to the Travel
Channel and they all pass yes they don't
even see the vision they don't see what
I see the problem with today is that it
well one of them said you know what if
you had a younger earth Nick guy
traveling with you so it's like that's
all the LA people now they want
diversity in them you know we're not
talking about diversity we're talking
about show you've been the same thing I
see look at let's be honest let's be
honest and throw our cards on the
[ __ ] table I barely like the six-hour
flight to New York I barely like that
flight okay if I'm the type of guy when
I went to prison into the purpura the
prison psychiatry department does a
[ __ ] test on you and the guy came to
me when then he goes if I had something
that you wanted I'll give it to you
because if you really want you taking
anything and I got really offended what
he meant by that was if I want something
I'll do it you know why don't travel
overseas from what that's a long plane
ride don't like it's not me guys it's
not man when I go to Jamaica and I see
those skinny chickens I can't eat that
[ __ ] I can't eat that [ __ ] I'm not into
that [ __ ]
yeah very weii I like those long plane
rides because I one of my obsessions is
my Delta frequent flyer status and I've
hit
iemon two years in a row this year they
made it even harder so this year you got
to spend you got it used to be a hundred
and twenty five thousand miles not bonus
miles not kicks from the credit card
purchases and [ __ ] that is 125,000 miles
sitting in the seat which is very
difficult to do so now they've raised it
to 140,000 this year and then you got to
spend like fifteen thousand dollars what
I get for Diamond status diamond is the
best so I you get to use the first-class
lounge every time you fly you're bumped
up I get bumped up to first class
probably 50% of the time I fly and then
you get these choice benefits and one in
Ybor you could use like eight coupons
for like not coupon whatever certificate
whatever you wanna call it to ensure
that you're bumped up to first class or
you can use it for like for
internationals and that's what I always
get so I love the long international
flights because you're [ __ ] smashing
it on the miles and I can use these
international upgrades and man that
first-class when you're on an
international flight it's like you're
depressed when you land it's like oh my
god you got the bed sleeper you got
movies you get ya like you yeah real
silverware and real food it's not like
that fellows sandwich at a [ __ ]
economy I mean you're talking like
you're talking like steak and whatever
and you know bringing around the warm
nuts and just and I don't even drink
anymore which is you know people there
there's you know they got high-end wines
there if you look at I've read something
about the breakdown of what of how a
flight makes its money like each flight
sixty percent of the profits is from
first-class so it's like the airline
really doesn't care about the people in
the economy so it's like they want to
like please those people in first-class
that's why like the first class lounges
get nicer the way they treat you in
first class is nicer and it's like it's
it's almost you're bummed out when you
get there it's so nice so
I'm yeah and that's important that's
another reason why you know I'll go to
Europe a couple times year I'll go to
Asia go to Australia and do gigs cuz I
mean I love going to those places but
also it's a I love being Diamond level
on Delta's graça Devon a helicopter on
this roof within an hour baby let me
know I hit the app but bombed kidding
and then also you get like a you get
like one or two free companion tickets
within the United States you can bring
your spouse or your partner or whoever
for free with you there's a really lot
of nice nice perks about it and when you
complain about something they they call
you back instantly they really they they
really really that's the that those are
the travelers they care about the most
let me know Delta or any airline dude I
like Delta I'll tell you what I used to
do because I'm gonna guarantee that
you'll get your luggage it's going
unless you get two thousand three miles
or a thousand bonus miles yeah do you
have 20 minutes to get your luggage so I
stopped I got a taco by the time I get
downstairs my lucky this is that picking
up a new butt picks me right up I got my
own gourmet food right well now here's
another thing with Delta when you're
Diamond level and you got a tight
connection you get off your plane this
has happened to me twice you got a tight
connection or even when I was in Seattle
I had plenty of time I didn't but they
did it anyway I guess it was slow for
them I'm getting off the plane and once
you step off the plane to go into that
little tunnel there was a woman standing
there with one of the little iPad and
had my name on it I'm like that's me she
goes oh and then she opens up the door
you don't even go up the tunnel you go
down the steps on the tarmac
if you look on when you fly Delta
lookout when you win the plane lands and
you're waiting to get off just look out
the window Delta's got at every airport
in America these little these these
Porsches and as I say Delta really small
in the window they got a little fleet of
Porsches for their diamond elite
passengers who have tight connections or
they just want to spoil them so I've
only had that happen to me twice but
stand up
I've talked with him about Stanhope
that's like a thing you're like whoa
it's really nice and the woman I in
Seattle like I had plenty of time and
she just like oh we just wanted the you
know let you know thank you we
appreciate your diamond status and then
she drove because I didn't I didn't have
a tight connection she drove all the way
around the airport and like you know
there's you do big planes and you're in
the foyer and this Porsche and you're
like oh my god and the woman goes well
she could Virge eyes back and she goes
well so um do you need anything and I
said well I got another I got an hour to
my flight can we take another lap she
goes yeah of course I can would just
drive a little slower this time
was really great so I mean it's it's
it's pretty pimp American used to be my
airline but after they merged with US
air
I think they treat you like animals I
think the attitude of their employees
changed the an event I've had people
dispute because Bert Kreischer loves
American so you know and he but he's
first-class level he whatever the
diamond equivalent is for America I
never reached that so an American
America I never reached that level of
American for 20 years all those you have
seen her first-class tickets right well
I used to be and then III had a few but
I have a few employees treat me like
[ __ ] and after that US Air merger I
thought they're they're the the airline
and I was a proud American guy I fly to
three I'm an American Delta and JetBlue
hi
it all depends where I'm going right I'm
very loyal to Southwest to San Jose I
can't deal with the did the corny jokes
on Southwest listen I got your phones
I got anyone who lost $300 wrapped in a
red rubber band
I haven't we have found your rubber band
I mean I grew up in Orlando they would
tell that joke on the Jungle Cruise and
like Southwest is still rattling off
these like I don't put the earphones on
I get the business like I'm gonna tell
you what I would I you salutely a guy
too
yeah I used clear I'm a kebab that's
another thing you get with diamond for
Delta you get clear for free yeah hey
[ __ ] you get your flight you get clear
for free
it's so great in LA
X and there's like a mile of line a mile
long and you go straight to oh my god I
love it away and everybody in lines like
who's this for
why is he get up and you just cut in
front of people moms and [ __ ] with kids
so you can go and sign up per flight cuz
I didn't want to do it every month but
no you're China it's you do it for a
year I think it's per month so it's 180
a month 180 a year right I don't know
yes Nelson when you're Delta diamond you
get it for free 180 years so I take what
twenty thirty flights a [ __ ] year
ganja okay that was a flight it's worth
it to cut bow I'll I have what don't
have it this time what piss me off yeah
what's happened ten of them have it in
this day yeah shop and if you have to
pay for it it's worth it diamond you get
it for free but what's a what I used to
do because you know comedian you're
struggling and you guys you know you got
to be economical for years I would go on
Expedia or Orbitz and I would always get
the cheapest flight no so I got tired of
being treated like an animal and about
five or six you and you know now I would
always try and get America and you don't
really get a cheaper flight mix breathe
you know you don't really get you know
nothing you don't get a deal it's a deal
it's a [ __ ] story no and so those
are the passengers that they give the
least priority on a plane yes you are
boarding in rouen city you are boarding
in zone six or seven there's no overhead
space when you get when you get on the
plane and you're gonna get like a
[ __ ] middle seat they don't give a
[ __ ] about you so you know I but I would
I would lean towards American because I
was trying to build up the point set and
then they pissed me off in three or four
times which made me say I'm gonna stick
with Delta and about five or six years
ago I made the choice to buy all my
tickets with Delta and only fly Delta
even if it's 50 $100 more and in the
long run that's better and because I get
treated like a king on Delta and another
thing you get to board with first-class
even if you're not in first class on
Diamond when your diamond which is great
because then you get a you're the first
one on the plane
you could put a tuba in the overhead you
got all the space in the world I do that
every week I don't [ __ ] around God I'm
the first one off the plane and the
first one on the [ __ ] plane I'm in
one [ __ ] D every week you understand
me I got that little thing look - you're
always in first class
I always [ __ ] first class I've been
with American for so long I get my ages
to get more money from the clubs I
[ __ ] finagle miles you get them to
pay for a first class I get them to pay
a little more if they pay 750 what's the
first class 850
so for yardstick I travel like a doctor
would I give a [ __ ] right what do I give
a [ __ ] from hello as I travel like a
[ __ ] gentleman I don't ever want to
get stuck on the long flight to New York
in the back an economy that's not gonna
are in the [ __ ] middle or on the way
back on the way back pop along one no
drum pop I don't like drama on the way
back at all I forget simple the first
flight pop I don't want to wait on the
lines popping and poppin in take no less
I get to the airport early to have eggs
I want to see the yolks I don't want to
see no yellow eggs you got yellow eggs
we don't do business I want to see the
yolk see understand me and I want to see
the bacon don't give me those ahead
point like I said like it that's like
stadium [ __ ] I'm gonna have a headache
for four days it should what that's not
happening my world I don't do much I
don't bother nobody
but when I fly I don't want no drama ch
yeah I got median you spent so much time
flying but that was the thing I was
getting beat up for years you're trying
to get mom tickets and then it finally
dawned on me that that's that's the way
for suckers man you know people fly once
a year I know scams the nobody knows why
because I'm gonna fly up to 27 you
follow me yeah plus you gotta remember
I've been flying I want my wife I went
to Disneyland last week with mercy for
graduation she graduated pre-k and my
wife said when was the last time you ate
I was ten I never thought about I came
right here by myself when I was eight
nine and 10 and went to Disneyland with
my uncle
if my own plane ticket Wow I'm applying
on myself for years they say come up on
myself and I said well we'll fly east
and we fly out together and then I take
the plane back to New York by myself I'm
gonna fly for years I love it but I know
how to scam people now I know what
listen you're never gonna upgrade to New
York Chicago we haven't been with the
airline that long those more people have
been there for 30 [ __ ] years and they
make our travel look like nothing
yeah they got good companies are paying
yeah I'm never gonna get I gotta run
into death okay take your time hurry up
let me get some shoutouts here real
quick that's what happens when you get
old you gotta pee every [ __ ] 10
minutes even if you don't drink [ __ ]
booze you got a pee how about Eddie
Torres a shout-out for him my man Joe
grant Tony rule jr. Debra hub stir
Zander Wilson
Stefan McBride Jason Pedroni and Joseph
Harris I love you [ __ ] don't
forget don't forget July 7th I'm at the
ice house 7:30 working out with uncle
Joey
and don't forget July 13th and 14th
we're at the [ __ ] some point in
Las Vegas
Lee's banned for life so you won't see
him at the South Point but don't worry
about nothing we're still doing bong
it's for Jesus don't worry about nothing
but it's good that you're learning about
flying people because it's [ __ ] look
nothing bothers me more than when I see
people they crush two weeks ago we all
fool of Vegas I go late take the fun of
the Birdman he took the fight like a
[ __ ] movie I thought he is but then
he started pay 60 for the [ __ ] for
the lift so it's 120 so that if you for
the extra 80 you fly right over here
like a doctor and he found me yeah
sometimes the man well I wasn't 60 was
35 but no I should have flown
I should just pretty boy like that's the
thing with you guys if you buy your
tickets sometimes right like why would I
get the [ __ ] date right when they
call me before I agree to the date first
off I love Delta I love American I love
JetBlue United is the Puerto Rican and
when you take some too few enough
i jewelry any time you think about
taking United pull up that video on
YouTube with that Chinese doctor but oh
that Chinese doctor you won't see him
again I wish I took a beat like that
guys he's got a long look at his [ __ ]
right now blow it doctor - is that so
you haven't heard from [ __ ] have you
you haven't seen him pop up in any
videos and then he's at a bank right now
just giving everybody 20 suck my dick
right now
Oh give us a [ __ ] he started to bother
his face from United he got a tattoo on
his face - little blood stain yeah -
Yellin out but I was gonna say first
thing I judge is what time you get me
back you told me you always scared the
first plane in the first plane out I
thought about first letter okay so I
have to beat your club Thursday one show
if I can fly at five or six and be in
your town by 2:00
I'll be in the hotel by three that's
four hours I can take a shower take a
two-hour yeah get room service read
downstairs and still make it to your
club for one show you told me that a
couple years ago I've done it if you're
coming out there a lot of times and I'll
take the first 6:00 a.m. flight out
which I got you I got that tip from you
which is it great cuz boom you're back
in LA I like [ __ ] ten and then you're
back in the more you want to sleep sleep
in your own [ __ ] bed yeah but for me
to sleep a fast 11 get up I gotta be at
the airport at 1:55 the flights delayed
then by the time I land in LAX at all
Helen LAX is 4:30 it's packed the 405 is
packed the Dodgers lost everybody's
pissed off [ __ ] you I'm not getting home
till 6:30 at night like a savage no not
worth it just get out of there early get
the [ __ ] out - why would you get to the
airport two hours a great tip man I used
to hate it I hate how shiny like I would
always think oh well you know get it
I'll get like a late afternoon flight
back so I don't have to yeah I didn't
work with the Agostino it was too late
for him they got a plane ticket because
I got so busy with Netflix and this and
that I didn't get the plenty at the
collusive casino so I didn't get him a
plane ticket so I said can I just give
you cash just do the drive and Saturday
day we were talking because we had the
gig was Saturday night
so the biggest in the drive up Friday
staying at your sister's because you
always go to Sacramento anyway to see
the sister I know they drive Saturday
the casino Mouse so sadly I'm outside
smoking a number with him and he does
I'm thinking about Lee with tomorrow no
listen bro I don't know if you know this
the worst Drive in the world for me is
that San Francisco that way why it's a
great Drive let's take the 101 take your
time I'm 55 I got one from the gray one
a bladder beer that's five hours no
matter how you slice it
yeah you're lucky and there's always
traffic stop and get some Anderson's pea
soup nobody I don't know buddy soup I
won't peace about what's the exercise
leave me the [ __ ] alone I've had piece
suit from 55 I got much time I got five
hours to drive them wave to people like
the Kennedys waving down the 101 I ain't
got that type of time so yeah I'm the
kind of guy that will stop at a roadside
by some cherries I used to I loved all
that [ __ ] yeah five-year-old you know I
can't go to San Jose get my car at 11
o'clock at night not get in till 5:00
and then you don't fall asleep till 6:30
7:00 and then you sleep two hours your
whole day is [ __ ] rule that's how you
do saying all that that's why for years
I didn't do San Jose for years they
would call me a you want to [ __ ] no cuz
you guys won't go for the plane ticket
I'm not doing that drive I'm not doing
that [ __ ] drive I hate that drive I
haven't been quite in the San Francisco
family convicted and ninety-eight and
renting a car and driving back and going
I'm never doing this drive again like
this was a big [ __ ] mistake but at
that time I had money from a commercial
talk about commercial yeah and I was
such a coke fiend I still slept on the
beach and like what I just had two
things on our label well I just pay the
59 for the hotel room in Santa Cruz what
the [ __ ] is wrong with me and I finally
got a hotel room that has the worst
driver I used to drive all over the
states you know we all did yeah but no
no but I mean like in in recent years
like when I wasn't living anywhere I
still had a car and when my dad was
still alive he lived in Anaheim and my
mom was in Orlando so
like if I would go to Asia I leave my
car in LA with my dad or go to Europe
leave my car in Florida with my mom and
then in the States I would book things
in blocks and work my would do like work
my way across the country over like a
month or two period
my wife travel with me and we loved it
like you know leaving from Orlando do
you like Atlanta Cincinnati Indianapolis
Chicago Minneapolis then Drive you stop
off in Montana and [ __ ] then you know
do gigs in Seattle and then Portland San
Francisco down and or
work my way across the bottom doing like
El Paso Dallas Houston New Orleans don't
get me wrong I love that [ __ ] I loved it
yeah that is that is something then
that's our soul that's the soul the
comedian that's when you first get into
comedy and even afterward and you just
get in the car and you tell your
problems to the highway yeah the highway
tells you to have problems saying I'm
saying in here out then you just take it
that's a different life that once you
accept you're in I got my wallet I love
all that [ __ ] yeah but no I mean like
from when they was started I was doing
that and sleeping in the car like you
did but I'm talking about in the last 10
years when I had a really nice used BMW
and my fabulous photographer European
wife and we were - we were making
adventures out of it I would like book
things with thinking of you know ah well
we'll work our way across country and
then we'll spend a week in Austin spend
a week in New Orleans just and that was
when I was still drinking and partying
and you know or like go across so we
spent a month in Montana six years ago
and then I go hit the go see the Crazy
Horse Memorial or you know like there's
it's about two miles from Mount Rushmore
is this they built their did theirs
taking them like a hundred years to
carve this this crazy horse on a horse
and Mount Rushmore could fit where the
UM the horse's head you ever heard about
this yeah yeah it's amazing
it's weird that you've really
taking advantage of the travel inside I
know a lot of comics that never will
take advantage like me I'll never take
advantage of that because I was kind of
scared part of this fear yeah there's a
lot of things I have traveling abroad
like in my world I got into this country
or anything I'm another train that's the
legs van yeah when they let me in one
path that sounds good
I'm good why [ __ ] spit in friend's
face
when was I right why come back and be
like wait a second you came in under Tom
Rhodes 1966 you got to go back to Cuba
over the [ __ ] deport mate it ain't
got that type of time right now so right
now let's leave the paperwork out what
is lets leave everybody how it is we
won't [ __ ] with you you won't [ __ ] with
us and okay we're gonna send the
postcard send the postcard and don't
wash your hands when you eat the sushi
just come back on the plane we get a
little sushi fingers almost live from do
you have a passport they yanked that
[ __ ] huh yeah man I'm good as
gold yeah I was I was born in Washington
DC baby yeah I'm like question as far as
I'm concerned a where I was born it was
a right it's just paperwork it's guided
we make believe we don't know nothing we
don't know nothing my paper works is one
thing my mother told me the young couple
to [ __ ] the belief so we'll just leave
it at that you know I'm saying what's
that will read the stay friends what's
that statement I agree to disagree yeah
will agree disagree I won't go to the
boy man and you won't come get me you
know was I yeah I never see me at the
border playing in cages little Mexican
kids for the soccer ball and [ __ ] every
day
they're gonna blow that up every day
they got these kids in the border well I
like it man like and I'm gonna do I'm
gonna give somebody got an Asian and I'm
gonna go back to Asia in August for two
weeks and you got club now I'm doing
yeah I'm doing what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do a weekend in Kuala Lumpur love
quality Malaysia's amazing the food
there is incredible it's a Muslim
country and it's but it's sexy Muslim
the women wear like colorful head
scarves it's hot and it's tropical so
like there's you Eve monkey no no no
Malaysia and Singapore right next to
each other and they both do this black
pepper crab crab is one of my favorite
things on the planet black pepper crab
is worth flying to Singapore or Kuala
Lumpur for and then in Malaysia they do
this
it's called murtabak which is just like
oh my god man it's I it's like I kind of
like roadie bread but with like minced
lamb and egg and chopped up onions in it
and there's like a curry sauce that you
dip it in I mean the farts that come up
around this stuff is better than lamb
and is okay and eggs you know what comes
out of your ass where your [ __ ] hate
that's what Isis smells like Bobby
ripping some Isis farts you know what
I'm doing Kuala Lumpur and that's one
it's one of my favorite places Malaysia
and then I'm doing Beijing olan Betar
Mongolia and then Shanghai and that'll
be like two weeks and then in October
I'm going back to Europe did I mention
I'm at the punchline in Philadelphia
yeah June 28th through the 30th yes let
me ask you into it so in October I'm
doing I've never been to Portugal I've
been invited by this Portuguese comedian
to do this comedy festival in Porto and
then he's also lining up a gig for me in
Lisbon never been to Portugal all my
European friends there favorite place is
Portugal they said it's like cheap it's
amazing cities are beautiful beaches are
incredible so I'm really excited to go
to I've got a week in Portugal and then
I got a week in Paris and hopefully
we'll find out very soon if I get the
green light I want to film my next hour
special in Paris the second week of of
October like October 14th just Sunday
that's the date I'm shooting for I'm
know soon iris Texas Paris France
I got a long history with Paris my first
love of my life I lived in San Francisco
with a girl woman from Paris Nottoli
we're still good friends first time I
went to Paris I was maced some guys
tried to rob me
I got a lot of great stories about there
anything what dangers hang himself the
in Strasbourg is that Paris no that's in
the south so then I'm going so after
Paris I'm doing Oslo and and then I'm
doing a comedy festival in Ireland in
Galway the last week of October so I got
all of October in Europe impossible to
do what we're gonna go your house I
think so that's pretty sad that guy like
that did everybody admired [ __ ]
wasn't happy like when Robin Williams
killed himself I thought man if that guy
wasn't happy none of us stand a chance
you know yeah I don't know and I'm bored
ain't had a kid - I couldn't imagine
it's pretty [ __ ] self to make money's
gonna solve your problems and sometimes
money just can't shut that little voice
in your head off you know I'm saying
we always think something's gonna shut
that voice off but we have to shut it
off it's kind of weird it's scary you
think about it but it's just something
that besides a passport or Delta that
you use on all your traveling is there a
certain briefcase or a jacket I don't
think I I'd really love to help you with
this you don't understand listen yeah I
know fake stuff um okay
and I know who really enjoy something
I've known you for 15 years first time I
met you
IIIi knew who you were but the first
time I met you showed me the second
episode of you interviewing the singer
from radar love and we connected on that
level and you were like a child
explaining it to me whether we were
doing blow whether it was 6:00 in the
morning and that you were like a child
you were so excited about this and you
have the same passion today about
traveling yeah you got all these [ __ ]
humps on TV you know what man it's so
true that
even if you shot a pilot that cost you
$30,000 would not get it didn't
understand about you eating I never
heard of a black pepper crab you know
you understand me like these are little
things that people don't catch that a
guy like me catches I wish I could do
what you did I [ __ ] hit it out of the
park the only reason you would fail is
if you didn't build it up before you
released it I can't do that for you Lee
can't do that for you your wife can't do
that for you only Tom Rowan could do
that I think you have a tremendous
project on your hands that could beat
them on the internet with your curse we
could smoke a bong hit ya
you're insane all right well I'm just
getting the funding for when you do when
you do these gigs international I mean
you know what Dane did Pittsburgh I want
you to go down to Jersey Shore you like
crabs will go to Tony River
well actually I'm doing Pittsburgh never
been to Pittsburgh like the first week
of does some nerve the last weekend last
weekend of November what they did it the
dump gonna do a gig deal yelling you as
you go to Thomas River and we'll get
those crap but Bourdain went every
[ __ ] hating all the toms river' we'll
get those web pages and we'll drop them
on the other side but I would do it if I
did a Travel Show there wouldn't be no
eating in it cuz that was his thing my
thing would all be comedy muscle you
said you yeah crab black pepper crab I
like any kind of crap don't worry about
[ __ ] what Dan or whatever I'm telling
you that will stop in Toms River will
grow some [ __ ] those those crab
things out and we go we smoked 10 joints
we come back the nets are filled we
bring in to Louie's house down in Toms
River he makes a spaghetti sauce you
dick was there he know if you understand
me you'll be calling the doctor go and
come help me I got a hard-on afraid in
our did you take my eye but no red brick
radiation clams from South Jersey
these things are keep you [ __ ]
[ __ ] ball like this we WA we what we
were 19 hours tremendously we were kids
we catch those clams
those crap bring up north are you
allowed to eat those listen it don't
matter you see this is why those [ __ ]
pollutions cancer crabs oh you put them
in a red sauce you put Italian bread and
dip it in that cancer sauce ooh you give
something to tasty a dick when they
swallow that sperm they have that taste
like it's bad mayonnaise and I'm saying
like when Leeds California really is
that special taste on this place we
don't like California Ron it's got
mayonnaise in it anyway but no seriously
old jokes aside better than oil crowd
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] let me tell
you something your true passion this is
always since I met you this has always
been one of your main focus of
conversation you know things that most
Americans do not know yeah you know do
not know him we'll never [ __ ] know
you know the comedy side of all these
other countries which is very [ __ ]
interesting Gabriel when he did is
special he talked about going somewhere
where'd he go and he said that the guy
picked him up was a comic his cousin was
a comic excuse me because of YouTube all
those international the Middle East
yes he went somewhere in the Middle East
and they were like going crazy over
Gabriel yeah
and he goes everybody was trying to tell
him jokes this [ __ ] because this you
know family is growing international all
over the world it's all over the world
in Asia there's comedy scenes all over
Asia it didn't exist 20 years ago have a
tremendous showing yeah bro and like I
said by the time you saw it I know you
got the talent
oh by the time you sell don't give it to
a white guy that's 24 yeah well they
give it to you you okay with blonde hair
the earring in his nose who's that with
a tattoo of viva pari on his chest and
the sperm shot and there was nothing
yeah well I mean you know I'm just one
day at a time you know I'm focusing on
doing that special in Paris and then
hopefully I hope it all works out man
if anybody's paid their [ __ ] dues
three times its you did you put high
school no I finished high school I'm not
offended I'm sorry I never went to
college I thought you quit high school
to do stand-up somebody no I started it
when I was 17 I was still in high school
I was in high school and I started quit
high school to start comedy Hicks or
know somebody Dwight the Slater there
was somebody who quit high school to do
comedy this CD I forget where the [ __ ]
was I loved high school are you kidding
are you I got the host of pep rallies
and the talent shows got to do the
afternoon announcements awesome like
Oviedo Florida when I grew up there was
a small town and everybody knew I wanted
to be a comedian so they let me do all
this they cuz I don't everybody knew I
was playing in the nightclub in Orlando
on the weekends I stopped going to
dances and football games I was going to
the comedy club what kind of cleaning my
window back there was an independent
Club when I started there it was called
the funny farm
and then a year later they changed it to
the unfortunate name of the Copa banana
what year was this I started 84 Christ
yeah Wow seven season Christ started
February 4th 1984 most seventeen years
old I had just landed in New York City I
was living in Aspen Colorado and I said
[ __ ] it I'm going back from my birthday
which is February 19th and I flew in on
the first out of the states like the
14th I had to up Stan so while you were
starting comedy I was starting my
journey criminal career you follow huh
how you could you like full senior Cuomo
I never made it
I got a deceptive alone with [ __ ] way
as you could tell I'm a [ __ ] atomic
man with a podcaster so I don't have
time to do crimes of passion I'm sorry
the [ __ ] yeah man and I graduated when I
was 18 and then the 1985 and then I went
right on the road like a month later now
you already know guard down at that time
no he didn't start he started like he
started like probably 88
something like that I was art I was
doing it like three or four years when I
remember when Billy came around on open
mic nights and I remember when Carrot
Top came and did open mic night they
shunned him because he had props he said
come back when you don't have props and
Darrell Hammond
I remember when Darrell was doing open
mic nights and he was doing the voices
and the characters and yeah man was
great and then it was a great club run
Bennington at a comedy club in
Clearwater Ron Bennington's comedy scene
and then that meeting him that was
really I was different down there man
because I was like he was like the first
comedian I'd ever seen who was like
talking about real [ __ ] and like like
just people just not be in hacks just
trying to be real and do some [ __ ]
quality [ __ ] and so down there in
Clearwater man it was Bennington and Jim
Breuer used to play down there there was
a lot it was it was really great it was
different than what was going on in
Orlando you know so it was a lot of good
what was going on so on land I'll have
how many comedy clubs it's the only one
the Copa banana eventually became
bonkers and oh [ __ ] yeah other than the
same Phillipos bought it and it became
bonkers but it was in like some it was
in these nightclubs these dance clubs
like the first one was Park Avenue and
then it was JJ whispers and these were
like this was like the hottest clubs in
Orlando so there would be a comedy show
from 8:00 to 10:00 then attended clear
out the chants no no disco with a side
small room where they had work comedy so
like the disco was already raging and
they're like being a young man I mean I
was I had a fake ID man I wasn't even
old enough to be in there and like I'm
meeting like women in their 20s 30s he's
older women man I had a great time I
loved it are you doing comedy in a room
I think some of the waitresses had sex
with me just for the novelty of you
being a kid yeah yeah yeah so you're
doing comedy next to a room that's
playing music and you could hear the
disc
music yeah not yeah I mean partially and
then this is Florida in the 80s so there
was a lot of cocaine and everybody
dressed like Miami Vice and everybody
thought that were Tony Montana and it
was interesting interesting time you
know [ __ ] time roads roads I can't wait
for the book to come out
most importantly I can't wait for you to
[ __ ] do this this little web series
this is the only way it's gonna work I
mean I was putting money into into doing
it years ago and it was only big of your
life shoots and you both had it in the
beginning for the first season I was
doing it I would call it extended arm
productions too because I had a camera
and I would film myself yeah doing stuff
I did that for years just again and it
would be it would cost a lot of money to
edit it and you know I didn't I know I
don't have the I don't have the money to
do it on my own you know
I need I need something to happen
there's gotta be a way way they tape you
and you go get off the plane shown what
has to happen will you check in you know
for a guy like me it would be
interesting
I just need the right guy I'm not gonna
watch some fake comic or a discovery go
to some [ __ ] no I don't want to watch
that I want to watch a friend of mine
tell his story do you know I'm saying go
to China
show me the toilets that already talked
about I have to [ __ ] and there's no
toilet paper make sure of it you know to
me I've never seen that stuff that not a
blow guy like my you know yeah and I'm
the type of guy that I think you're one
of the most interesting comics working
like if I was a real comedy fan I'd go
see you every time you weren't down
because I know you're constantly right
you know one of those guys that brings
the same [ __ ] every time I see ya you're
constantly writing and I would ask you
questions afterward I would ask you
stupid questions okay I'm thinking like
going Australia whatever line should I
flight because I know you would take 20
minutes on explain yeah well people
email me all the time and they'll ask me
for travel advice and I do it all the
time and it's like there's a lot of in
and guy wrote me though they a man my
daughters are 21 and they're going to
Amsterdam
well I just told this other guy last
week all the Amsterdam things did you
know so I don't know I need to put out a
travel book or something a travel book
you know who was there gonna put the
[ __ ] book out about how to pack who
had a friend somebody had a friend the
friend of ours and put a book up
yeah that's how you hit no no you asked
me what I take with me on my travels
yeah like where is there anything that
I'm every trip well I'll tell you what I
you take because it really helps you be
a better travelers there a guide is
there a video was there a watch no
[ __ ] I'm reading but there's this
things like you know bring your own soap
and a thing because there's little Hotel
soaps or you know even in luxury hotels
are usually kind of small there's I use
to me luggage I used to use travel Pro
but they something happen to them you
buy a travel probe luggage you just cost
about 300 350 you get on it so you get
them on sale well it's just quality
luggage is always that expensive but it
used to be worth it because it traveled
pro bag used to last I would get four or
five years out of a travel pro bag I eat
one bag
that's suitcase oh my all right all
arguing well that was over listen to me
so listen that's well the last travel
Pro bags I had only lasted the the one I
had one lasted two years and then it
fell apart and then the last one I had
lasted like a year year and a half and
it fell apart so you drop in $400 on a
piece of luggage and it only lasts a
year or two something happened to travel
Pro they stopped the quality product
they were offering before the seams
would bust the zippers would bust they
and I said [ __ ] that I'm not using them
anymore so I got I the last two bags I
got I got I got a carry-on bag from to
me and I I love this that's the greatest
you know it's
regulation size fits under the seat over
the head and then it's got this zipper
in the back where you pull out the your
computer so when you're going through
the thing it's beautifully designed it's
great secret pockets on it it's got
pockets for everything but it's this
back zipper there you go to the metal
detector and you got your computer comes
out you feel like a pro and you're
zipping through there especially with
clear boom you through this I'm really
me so then only one I already have what
I asked them to sponsor my podcasts like
two years ago never even got a reply and
then the the the the quality to me bag I
bought for $1,000 the piece of luggage
so the carry-on thing is like 300 350
and it's beautiful bag so my wife was
like man are you gonna spend $1000 on
this piece of luggage and I'm like
listen you know I'm a comedian I'm a
headliner I got to show up with the
quality stuff you know and I don't need
some punk-ass Travelpro zippers bustin
and I don't want to travel around oh now
I'm gonna hump it out with a year with a
bag that's got a busted zipper [ __ ] that
I'm a professional traveler you know
what I'm saying
so I spent the thousand dollars on the
Tumi bag and I really believe in this to
me stuff man they make beautiful luggage
sure they cover like compartments or
anything I mean they they got different
kinds you can get the kind where the old
style or I like to fold over garment bag
kind so it's got like inside pockets
it's beautifully designed you got a
plate some of the shoes place for the
socks place for the underwear and then
you're hanging the thing open
beautifully and then you got outside
pockets which I put my toiletries in in
case when I land I need to get the
toothbrush or something you know and
then just the outside pockets are
beautiful so check this out last
December I was playing in there's his
tour of Switzerland I've done it three
times and it's great you do it's a week
of one night as across Switzerland so
you do Geneva loose on Basel and Zurich
and I had a day off and I went to vevey
and I went to Charlie Chaplin's house
was great so flying back actually the
tour ended in Basel this time so I had
to fly back from Basel to Amsterdam and
then Amsterdam to to New York and then
Arno Amsterdam to Atlanta and then
Orlando for Christmas so Amsterdam got
snowed in so I got stuck in Basel
Switzerland for an extra couple of days
which isn't a bad place to be stuck in
Switzerland and when I finally got out
and in Basel Switzerland the airport
they used some kind of machines with
claws the bottom of my beautiful
expensive bag got these these ripped him
it got these it got these these big I
don't know I think about the size of
your thumbs he's too big Nick's man took
a photo of it when a media like I picked
it up and then my first thought was holy
[ __ ] I go to so I did when I was on KLM
which is connected to Delta but I bought
the ticket through Delta because I buy
everything through Delta and then when I
landed in am stock accom Tom case you
listen when I got the back-right landed
in Amsterdam and I got my bag back I saw
the things and I went to the to the the
complaint luggage area and I took photos
of it and Delta Airlines can I kept the
receipt for the thing paid me the exact
amount of money for so the so the oh
[ __ ] I'm spending a thousand dollars on
luggage
they sent me a check for a thousand
dollars so because so now I look at that
luggage and it's got these thumb-sized
scratched Nick's on it and I love it
because that means I got a free piece of
luggage forget they pay you Tom Rhodes
at the Philadelphia punchline June 28
through 30th
always a pleasure Tom Rhodes are we
learn something I love you so much Joey
learn some follow Tom roads if you're a
traveler you're interested in traveling
these guys are so / M re I listen to
that [ __ ] and they know what the [ __ ]
they talk about and they're passionate
about it it's something sitting at the
griddle and some guys like I went to you
know how he always you know dropping all
these names [ __ ] you you're an amateur
you [ __ ] you went over there sucking
dick the whole way they spanked you we
go over there
Tom roads are respectable individual
anyway when are you with June 28th to
the 30th June 28th through the 30th I'm
at the punchline in Philadelphia
damn yeah that's a good [ __ ] date I
need to be so have you ever done this
West Nyack New York yes how is that I'm
there and I'm this I was gonna ask you
how because I've never been to read this
tremendous trimmer and I'm like I had to
look that up on a map good pizza
August 30th through September 2nd funk
yeah you're there you're 45 minutes out
of the city or my know my old haunt
what's it like that it's nice
listen you go to the hotel yeah a couple
numbers we mmm Italian food
mmm I got something else is it a nice
town barbecue let's pretend you shot 18
people and you came in and you need to
hide out that's where you go West lag no
verified but the audience's there
Brooklyn the Bronx in northern New
Jersey in Queens my aunt and I a Koosh
[ __ ] last time I did some dude heckled
me he went to the bathroom three guys
came in hit a bottle West Nyack is
heavy-duty but his head in the toilet
heavy-duty
Nyack is heavy do leave ain't [ __ ]
around over there
very interesting good people yeah man
have a good time I'm going Pittsburgh
like the last week in November yeah
Pittsburgh in price last weekend of
November I knows and then I'm really
excited about Philadelphia next week
because it's the first time I'll be
there since I [ __ ] busted my head
open and
was like such as four years ago that's
significant
no change your life forever I'm gonna
you know I think I'm gonna go I want to
go ten years and then I might start
having a glass of wine and have a beer
we'll see how old you know 51 so you'll
be 57 when you attend by that time
you're waiting more a drink wine you'll
say what's the big [ __ ] deal anyway I
don't know man I I like going to Paris
and Rome and sitting in cafes and
reading books no one else understands so
you know so we're sure all the luck in
the world
you're a great man you're a great comic
you're a great friend brother I love you
with all my heart I'm happy you came on
today and don't forget to follow Tom
Rhodes and the [ __ ] flying Jew over
there my brother my little brother don't
forget the ice house July 7th and
Southpoint the 13th and 14th listen like
I told you in the beginning of the
[ __ ] show you know I [ __ ] around with
you people as far as I when I fly a lot
I'm always on it [ __ ] Emil I'm always
on the smile there's no checking me I'm
always on you don't see me travelling
like a little Japanese do with a mask on
this [ __ ] day I take two [ __ ] on it's
and nobody [ __ ] with uncle Joey you
understand me whether it's the Alpha
brain whether it's the chocolate Mexican
chocolate protein powder listen on it is
the [ __ ] good now they got on at 6:00
it's an in-home training program for six
weeks transformation it transforms your
[ __ ] body understand me
go to on a dot-com right now impress in
church BAM get 10% off delivery right to
your [ __ ] house just like that number
two I'm a fat [ __ ] people Joey well gede
fuji fuji get the best you understand me
go to fuji sports right now
fuji sports.com why Joey why the [ __ ]
should I go why cuz that gays a quality
quality quality quality quality you can
hang on them dangle on them
I found a noogie from three years ago
it's a white guy but it's black some
people hanging on my cow I don't give a
[ __ ] I never ripped it understand me
why quality like joy what gear should I
get you can get the cycle the Seiko s e
i cal 2.0 me
I recommend the super Raider it's 1:35
do you get the 10% off that's the best
gear for your [ __ ] money but the
all-around ease the ones under $100 they
do the trick to pro go to fuji sports
calm right now and press enter CH bam
and get 10% off again delivered right to
your [ __ ] crib I want to thank Tom
Rhodes I want to thank the Christ killer
Church and I'll see you [ __ ]
next Monday morning ready to rock you
understand me an attention ready to
fight off the [ __ ] Koreans don't
believe the hype stay black have a great
weekend and that's it kick this [ __ ]
me Lee I'm ready to stab a [ __ ]